i got one free so what about vladimir
putin do you think he's an unplugged
alpha i would say yes he is he is he's
definitely a billionaire too
he's the richest man in the world they
think you know that they hide all his
[ __ ] money you know that would not be
i don't know if he's the richest in the
world but i know he's got lots of he's
got billions for sure
dude he's got more bodies than hillary
clinton behind trump he must what about
trump he's you know he's dude's
unplugged he's repelled you know the
unplugged alpha what no not red pelt not
at all no he he talks about in his books
he prefers being married
well he also prefers a lot of other
things while he's married too right
if oh yeah that's true that is true
yeah i take that back i think i mean he
is he is pretty base in his book um no i
do take that back actually in his book
uh i just read uh think big and kick ass
in business
uh he talks about and like like blatant
he's like i've screwed a lot of women in
my life a lot of women are married a lot
like just like blatantly says i screwed
a bunch of women in my life
and uh he the way he talks about chicks
he's pretty base too but i think he got
a little bit based as he got older
because he had you know three failed
marriages under his belt i believe right
ivanka the american [ __ ] marla
marla and marlon
trump is very trump
prior to becoming the president really i
think even during the presidency um has
always been very conscious of his brand
and and as not older and once he decided
he's got to be president he's got to
sort of put out this you know i'm
married i'm a i've changed i'm a mature
guy now i'm not like grabbing him by the
[ __ ] anymore um that's when he starts
getting into you know supporting women's
issues and that kind of stuff
yeah but i mean there's got to be a
difference with some of these people
between what they say in public and how
they
maybe really view things and how they
really behave right it's all of them
well that's i mean anthony bourdain was
ostensibly very alpha before he put a
noose around his neck because of asia
argento all right so
or was he famous
i think he's not alpha what was this
he had that i mean even the perception
though
no but here's what about because like
rich remember when you were talking
about the guy [ __ ] on you for
talking that thing about women or elon
musk in that what was the answer people
gave you it was like yeah but look at
how much money he made yeah people are
treating money like some kind of
measuring stick to anything yeah no
installation yeah it's not the same
thing like i'm talking more specifically
about on like unplugging from the lies
like a plugged in beta is different from
an unplugged alpha right
and elon musk has more money than god i
mean he's you know he's loaded i mean he
could he could put all of his [ __ ] on a
rocket go to the moon and set up a
colony over there and you know have like
a harem of like you know like he can get
divorced five times and still be a
billionaire if he loses half of his net
income every time he's like insulated
from this he doesn't even really need to
care
yeah there's going to be a pergamos as
possible and he's like whatever i'll
make another billion superhero from a
guy that's talking about it being social
engineering only selected people get to
become billionaires and they must be
blue pill betas to set example for men
i'm not sure about that i'm not sure
about that i think the people that
become well maybe
i think the people that become extremely
wealthy are people who have
managed to play the system to
some degree you know i think i think
what rich was saying really you know
managed to sort of like you've got to be
pretty machiavellian haven't you to get
to get there you know that means get
that far i don't think these guys are
all some of them are for sure i mean
some of the most
most entrepreneurs that
most entrepreneurs that you'll get
inside their head on you realize that
almost all of them are quite
machiavellian they are exactly so so i
wouldn't say they're all these blue pill
sims who
society is put up to be to be role
models i don't i don't i don't buy that
i gotta i gotta cut i got an interesting
point here is that i think that when
guys get to be like you have to be on
your game to be a billionaire right i
mean i i mean unless you like somehow
just stumble into it doesn't happen but
it's worse right unless you get unless
you're a woman you go billions by
divorce yeah you probably have you
probably have been that's been your
lifelong thing that the reason why you
have those billions is because that's
what you have exclusively focused on and
isn't that what
most sort of success
you know gurus talk about just don't
like ignore women uh you know what was
it uh uh you know ignore women and
acquire currency right that's the whole
thing is just stay in your game right
just
chase excellence right just keep going
keep going keep going and at the
exception of
understanding women and i have done at
least two shows where i've talked about
this before is like i think that you can
do both the same i think you should be
able to do both at the same time because
if you don't you'll be at a severe
disadvantage once you have that success
once you have that excellence once you
have that money and we can see it here
in guys who have a lot of money and look
at the choices that they make or look
how they get rolled by women either
putting a noose around their neck or
they get rolled to the tune of 33
billion dollars because all they've ever
done is focus on one thing and that's
the money aspect remember make money
make muscles learn game all they do is
say you know what screw the rest of this
[ __ ] i'm just gonna go and do and make
money that's all i'm gonna do and when
they get to that point they become a big
mark because the women's especially
predatory women especially women like
lauren sanchez sees the richest man in
the world and he's a blue pill beta
chump and he's having marital problems
with his with his wife of god knows how
long and and when they were kind of you
know coming up and he was a dork and she
was a dork and now they're not dorks
anymore and so suddenly they're
splitting up and she sees that of course
she is that's that's like the that's
like the biggest juiciest biggest fish a
predatory woman can have is that and
he's just waiting they're like oh yeah
this is the way i like it this is what i
want right this is how i this is how i
am
and i got a point
so is it because all they ever do is
focus on one one thing
you